you
I keep going back for some reason on
this podcast two basketball references
but LeBron James who read all his
interviews where he talks about his
number one his number one thing that's
most important to him when training or
anything like that or nutrition or
practice even like the number one thing
most important thing to him is sleep
like yeah sleep cannot get in the way of
anything and he rigorously sleeps nine
to ten hours a night and takes two to
three hour naps every day and he has he
has his own personal hyperbaric oxygen
chamber he travels with and like yeah
that's a big topic so hyperbaric oxygen
can increase stem-cell production it
also stimulates the release of those
stem cells and those stem cells can go
in and hone in on sites of injury and
inflammation and enhance they in repair
processes so it's debated on how that
works but if they hone in and they
collect in a certain area they also
release various growth factors that can
help in skeletal muscle protein
synthesis and and repair may be
anti-inflammatory effects yeah so I'm
not convinced of the science but a lot
of people send me papers and say look at
this should I be using a hyperbaric like
NFL players and things like that kind of
stuff yeah and I say you know it look I
haven't seen any big but clinical trials
but the basic science kind of says it's
there I know Stephen Thumb who's also
funded by the office of Navy research
was - for one of the first to show that
hyperbaric oxygen therapy almost works
like this drug gm-csf
which is a sort of an activator of of
our stem cells and it can recruit
increased levels and it's used
therapeutically in cancer patients and
different patients that it almost has
the same ability as this is drug which
is extremely expensive to actually
influence the production and the release
of stem cells really so there was a joke
out there gm-csf and I think it's Luke I
nor neupogen
you know if you go these are very
expensive drugs that are used for a
number of applications some of them
experimentally for like neurological
diseases but also cancer patients and
stuff use them for for four different
applications so so granule granule is
say ya see ya
GM CSF and g-csf and GM CSF so Luca and
Newton so these are drugs I'm not super
familiar with but I became familiar with
it when some discussions were about
hyperbaric oxygen we're referencing
these drugs in relation to the ability
ability of hyperbaric oxygen to recruit
and stimulate the production and release
of stem cells that can enhance you know
tissue injury and repair so so there is
I get a lot of questions about
hyperbaric oxygen therapy and athletes
and okay there's some I just say the
jury's still out but I think okay and I
do that to be protective because my
contracts are actually to study the
negative effects of hyperbaric oxygen
over study oxygen toxicity seizures
which are the seizures that are
generated from hyperbaric oxygen being
too high so I study the negative
studying the negative effects of
high-pressure oxygen and why we need to
avoid it and develop mitigation
strategies against it but understand
that hyperbaric oxygen therapy is within
a defined limit and that limit is set by
the potential to get oxygen toxicity
seizures so within that therapeutic
limit it can have anti-cancer effects
that I talked about you know it can have
there's 14 different fda-approved
applications so an emerging application
could be recovery of athletes you know
from this and I think there are these
home hyperbaric chambers that you can
get on eBay for like 15 right to 2500
they may provide some benefit if you're
a high-end athlete and it gives you that
0.5% you know benefit or if you're
recovering faster you know that it may
be some to invest in I mean science is
pointing into it but it's not I'm not
completely sold on is there any any
benefit to someone like you know like
you or I to have that in their home kind
of like as a therapeutic thing for
someone who just casually works out or
wants to be healthier yeah well you know
I I communicate a lot with vets so
people with traumatic brain injury and
concussions and I think sadly this is an
area that's not fda-approved so I would
encourage people to check out you know
the use of hyperbaric oxygen for
traumatic brain injury concussions and
we know that hyperbaric oxygen at very
high levels is a stimulant to the brain
and you can overstimulate it to have a
seizure right but when it's done at
lower levels lower therapeutic levels it
can augment and it can reduce
inflammation it can stimulate processes
where the adaptive response is the
repair of the injury and when you have a
concussion or a blast injury its
rupturing blood vessels so you have
these hypoxic pockets and when you go
like these areas of the brain that don't
have enough oxygen that's what I mean by
that
so hyperbaric oxygen therapy can restore
oxygenation into those areas and start
to enhance the healing process in the
brain so there's a lot of data to
support it and we will be presenting at
hyperbaric oxygen therapy conference
2020 and we're a lot of vets will be
talking about this NFL players and I
think we need more research but I think
the research is pretty good with stroke
injury and hyperbaric and animal models
and now some evidence in patients so
it's not an fda-approved application but
another consideration that needs more
attention federal
if you have a traumatic brain injury a
concussion or stroke I think people
should look into I'm not gonna advocate
it because I need to stay within the
realm right but I think people really
need to look at the potential for a
hyperbaric oxygen therapy and we're
always trying to get research to study
this because I feel it's one of the most
important topics that need to be studied
brain injury traumatic brain injury and
using the hyperbaric oxygen in addition
to ketosis so the two together we feel
would be very therapeutic for recovery
of patients especially if it's done
immediately after but even patients
maybe that had the injury a while back
we think it would have some benefit when
they start Wow well that's been a bunch
that's been a incredible amount of
knowledge is dropped I really appreciate
you doing this man I've kept you here
for about two hours now
yeah man absolutely it's a it's a
privilege people to have someone like
you on here so hopefully we will get the
opportunity to do it again in the future
and and oh yeah tell everyone where they
can find you online and learn more about
what your what you're doing or yeah go
to we have a company ketone technologies
LLC but that company is more research
and development but we have a website
that talked about what we do as a
company and and also keto nutrition is
really my main information website I
don't sell any products on that but if
there's products on there that I have
used and recommend and that I use
personally and there's consultants on
there there's podcasts on there like the
Tim Ferriss Joe Rogan podcast are on
there and stuff so it's more of an
information website for people and it's
kind of like a one-stop shop and we also
have a blog so check out the blog we've
hit a lot of topics that we've discussed
and the blog will go into more depth and
detail on each of those topics what is
the blog called it's if you go to keto
nutrition Arg okay it's a dot word site
it's just the blog so just on the bar at
the top just click on blog and it hits
things from different types of ketone
supplements - diabetes - all sorts of
topics on there so yeah
but it gets into a little bit more
detail